it's so easy to be great nowadays
because everybody else is most people
are weak the whole thing about comfort
zones is if you live in one for too long
that becomes your norm you can outwork
anybody how bad as they all need
motivation watch the top ten with
believe nation what's that belief nation
is heaven I believe in you and this
channel is designed to be part of your
daily success routine so let's get your
motivation to attend and get you
believing in you grab a snack enjoy
today's lessons from a man who went from
growing up in an abusive household
struggling in school and with being
overweight to completing SEAL training
and US Army Ranger School and becoming
one of the greatest endurance athletes
in the world he's David Goggins and here
is my take on his top 50 rules for
success also if you want to know what
David Goggins has to say about
confidence and excellence check out my
254 series where every day for the next
254 days I will send you a morning video
for free to help you build your
confidence the links to join are in the
description below you will never learn
from people if we always tap-dance
around the truth everything I didn't
want to do is what got me to where I'm
at today
okay let's take it off with rule number
one go to Ward's truths I came home one
night from work spraying for cockroaches
and long story short I turn on the
Discovery Channel and I saw some guys
going to Navy SEAL training and they're
going to hell week and they're getting
their ass just beat you know in out of
the water
guys ringing the bell there was
suffering and I was waiting like 297
pounds and I had to make a change in my
life you know I was at all-time low and
I wasn't going anywhere and I was
exactly what everybody said I was gonna
be which was nothing so I had to make a
change what was it about seeing
suffering that's that's really
interesting and I actually get it but I
want to hear you explain it why
suffering was the thing that triggered
that thought well for me growing up I
came from a horrible background I got
called [ __ ] every day of my life
growing up lived in a small town the
Klan headquarters at that time was about
20 minutes from where I lived the one of
the high ups in the KKK son stabbed
behind me in two classes so you called
me [ __ ] a long time I got my first car
they spray print [ __ ] we're gonna kill
you on it so I was just an insecure
scared kid and the only way I could find
myself was to put myself through the
worst thing possible I'm gonna say the
exact opposite of what the world today's
world is saying so we read a bunch of
books nowadays as humans we we want to
find out how to be someone else what we
don't do is we don't go inside so
literally turn yourself inside out read
the book that says like we're writing a
book every day four lives every day
we're seeing who we are as people when I
was growing up I I lied for people to
accept me because I didn't accept myself
so I would make up stories so you so
then you would accept me into your world
I would uh everything I did was for
someone else to like me it was until I
started reading my own book about how
pathetic I was as human being I could
blame my dad I can blame kids at school
I could blame having health issues ATD
my mom not being around great mom but
she was doing her thing I could blame a
lot of people and that's the book I was
reading and I put it off on everybody
else it was until I say you know what
for me to fix this I get a read what the
hell what the [ __ ] is wrong with David
Goggin not blame anybody read my books
okay I'm afraid of my shadow how can I
overcome that go into military get your
ass kicked
do things you hate to do be
uncomfortable every day of your life
Roger that I'm not the smartest kid in
the world okay it says somebody saying
oh no you're smart no no don't say that
to yourself I said to myself no I'm a
dumb okay Roger that how you get smarter
educate yourself so the things that we
run from we run it from the truth we run
it from the truth man so the only way I
became successful was going towards the
truth as painful and as brutal as it is
it changed me it allowed me to become in
my own right
Who am today rule number two have a
cookie jar
David tell him about the cookie jar
the cookie jar is something I invented
as you all know your mom has a cookie
jar and sometimes you might have an Oreo
sometimes you might have a chips of
Hawaii sometimes you might have a over a
raisin cookie you never know is this in
there my cookie jar has every single
failure and success of my life
sup my overcame so what happens in this
in time of life when you're stressed out
and things get bad even the hardest guy
in the world me
everybody thinks and I think I'm the
hardest guy in the world you got to
believe that you got believe you are
something I will in my mind reach into
my cookie jar and sometimes you forget
how hard you are in times of need
because you're you're stressed but you
forget I'm a Navy SEAL I'm a ranger I'm
this and that but you forget all that
cuz your life sucks I calm down take
that one second get control of my life
reaching the cookie jar
while you got caught [ __ ] your whole
life and you're now the only person
history do justice and this put it back
in the cookie jar reset my mind you have
to remind yourself of how badass you
really are in times of need that's the
cookie jar rule number three get out of
the routine so many of us are on cruise
control myself included and we get into
our daily routine and routines are
unbelievable but routines can also be a
rut only if you really challenge
yourself and push yourself and get out
of your routine your comfort zone can
you get better like you can't improve
when you're on autopilot so you have to
set goals and you have to set challenges
that you don't necessarily think you can
do we're gonna push yourself way further
than you think you can to improve so you
got to get out of the complacency of the
routine whole thing about comfort zones
is if you live in one for too long that
becomes your norm it never allows you to
get experience gained knowledge game any
kind of mental toughness well I learned
that we all have a reserve tank that
we're all capable of doing so much more
than we think we can and only by really
tapping into that reserve tank whether
it's in business whether it's in
physically you want to get more fit only
when you really push yourself and push
your limits can you find out what you're
really made of and what's in your
reserve tank and I mean he taught me
that every single day and it just led to
me getting better in the various buckets
in my life as I tapped into that reserve
tank yeah don't be you know we call it
the 40% rule that's something that David
kind of told me and shared with me and I
bought into it and it's but it's proved
effective not just in working out but
even in business or my family life it's
like when I'm frustrated when I'm done
when I hit a roadblock when things get
complicated you have so much more in you
rule number four stick it in your skin
people I said man you cuss all the time
why well I hate to say it the best way
for me to get how I feel across I can't
steer and say you know what I went
through hell week it meant it was it was
really hard know that
takes her damn soul rips it inside out
and then they say now we're going to
start it it allows me to express where I
was at at a point of my life if I won't
give you all of me why the hell am I
here why how will you learn from me
people take so much offense to me you
will never learn from people if we
always tap-dance around the truth oh god
I love that
we tap-dance around the truth by finding
the right words I don't hurt you because
you have thin skin no tighten up people
it's okay
trust me it's okay you might be called
[ __ ] one day it's okay you might be
called some Jewish word or some [ __ ]
or gay word it's okay let them call you
that what are you going to do now they
don't own your life how are you going to
control that now how are you gonna flip
it upside down and say Roger that now
I'm going to harness this and you read
about me years from now how that's the
question how are you going to do that
thicken your skin become more of a human
being don't be afraid of the reflection
in the mirror because that's all you can
be afraid of once you overcome the
reflection in the mirror you've done it
rule number five break through the walls
literally broke all the metatarsals in
my feet stress fracture shin splints
everything the pain throw with my body
I've been through every chain another
man Ranger school hell week three times
all kind of stuff this event I'm
explaining to you right now
explain to you in detail was the worst
thing I've done in my entire life pain
wise this is not realizing your being is
capable of going to limits unknown to
most people this is where hardness comes
in people can read a book on hardness
and tell you about mental toughness and
hardness but until you put your body
through hardness it realized that
there's walls and doors you must break
through and once you break through them
you are amazing and your body resets but
we are scared to get to that wall
because that wall says what stop right
but every wall has a what a door you got
to get that key with your pocket and
don't be scared to seuss understand that
door
rule number six ask yourself what is I
would like to know when you're in that
moment failing mm-hmm and you have to
keep going what do you say to yourself
what if a lot of times I'll be the tours
at Mile Run or something like that and
I'm all jacked up body's broken mines
broken spirits broken I started to say
what if I can pull this off when I first
walked into the Navy SEAL recruiters
office he looked at me and said only
been 35 african-americans and 70 years
make it through you know I said to
myself what if I can be the 36 it's the
what if I can pull off a miracle what if
I can become someone that no one thinks
I can be and just that just means
talking about that I have the hair
growing up on my arms because it makes
me just like what if I can be that guy
that people who called [ __ ] and this
and that and now I'm speaking at tom
ferry event what is
that's it rule number seven be driven so
this the first ultramarathon wasn't
smart at all at all just so basically
happened was I was at military freefall
school with Morgan Latrell marcus
luttrell if you guys don't know was the
lone survivor the guy he was in a bad op
op went bad he was the only Navy so that
lived long story short you got to get
the book read lone survivor great story
Morgan is Marcus - Charles twin brother
and I was there with Marcus so what
happened was myself and Morgan were
freefall school at the same exact time
Marcus was in the worst incident in
still history so I knew that Marcus
might be dead he wasn't dead everybody
was dead so I actually bought Morgan you
know I actually told Morgan hey man your
brother wasn't a bad incident I don't
know if he's alive I'll know what's
going on long story short
Marcus is alive and I go on to want to
raise money for families all these guys
die they all had kids I want to raise
money for the Special Operations Warrior
Foundation it's the foundation where
100% tuition goes to these kids to go to
college you know full tuition whatever
so I found this great foundation I'm
gonna raise money for it so I see no
what I have to Google something that's
that's evil something very hard I knew
nothing about ultramarathons
I hadn't even run a marathon I knew
nothing about this world so I googled
that they know the top 10 hardest races
in the world and what comes up is about
water 135 so Hernan 35 mile race through
Death Valley in the summertime I thought
it was a stage race I thought was a race
where you run like 20 miles set up camp
you know
barbecue outside and then go run some
more the next day so I called the race
director up at the race and said hey
Chris name is Chris Causton I want to do
your race so we had a long conversation
you know I was I was much heavier then
and I had to put running shoes on over a
year
how have area at this point I'm around
between 240 to 270 whoa I'm in there I'm
in that register I've my witness buried
a lot through the SEAL Teams and I was
still team so I was a heavy guy
but the long and short of it all was I
am put running shoes on in over a year I
was a big-time power lifter I lifted
weights heavy that's what I did I got
back home from Iraq we straight to
freefall school and then this happened
so I called Chris Kozma up on a
Wednesday he says look man the only way
you can qualify for my race is to run
100 miles at one time in 24 hours or
less there happened to be a race that
Saturday so 4 days later and he said if
you qualify by running 200 miles or less
in 24 hours I will consider you my race
I'm gonna cut to the chase I signed up
for this race it's called the san diego
one day where you run around a one-mile
track for 24 hours to city miles you can
get my goal was 100 miles so I got 2
miles 70 and I cleared 70 miles in like
12 13 hours pretty quickly but I was
done my feet were broken
I was stretched fractured shin splints
muscles were tearing I was in bad shape
I was eating rich crackers and drink
this that's all I had no water didn't
know what the hell I was doing out there
had on some tube socks it was just
ridiculous it was it was a clown show so
I sat down at Mile 70 and at this time I
was married and I look at my wife and I
was like I'm messed up bad
so I literally start to turn white and
when a black guy turns white you're
pretty so here I am I'm off up in this
chair I'm at Mile 70 they got 30 miles
to go I'm jacked up I got to go to the
bathroom in the bathrooms like 20 feet
from me supporter potty I can't get all
the chair so I'm peeing blood down my
leg whoa whooping up my back and I got
30 miles to go and I'm I can't stand up
cuz my my blood pressure's all messed up
I've been in three whole weeks Ranger
school overcome so many obstacles in my
life this last 30 miles of this race is
when I realized a human being is not so
human anymore we have the ability
go in such a space if you're willing to
suffer and I mean suffer your brain and
your body once connected together can do
anything and this 30 miles was the
life-changing moment I was out of it I
was in the worst pain in my entire life
I was to me on the brink of death and I
was able to Chuck this 30 damn miles
into small pieces I was so driven and
I'm not gonna say motivated cuz
motivations crap motivation comes and
goes when you're driven whatever's in
front of you will get destroyed so I sat
in this chair and I was so driven to
succeed in this race and at this time
everyone's were you thinking about the
guys that died and I'm not gonna lie to
you I wasn't this became a personal
thing this became me against this race
me against the kids that called me
[ __ ] me against me it just became
something that took so so violently
personal and I broke this thing down
into small pieces I said okay I got to
get nutrition I gotta be able to stand
up before I can get off this curve and
golf this chair and be able to go 30
miles so I went through all these small
steps and I was able to stand up and
then from standing up
I was literally walking around with my
wife at the time and she goes you not
gonna make the time she goes you're
young you're walking like 37 minute
miles I got tomorrow 81 and the second
she said that I'm not gonna make the
time I ran the last 19 miles non-stop
and I can show you right now when we get
done with this math fact I want to show
you right now this was years ago and I
had to put compression tape on my own
and I had so this was years ago I had
literally the size of half dollars I had
to get compression tape and I taped up
my ankles and i taked up my feet and
that's how I got through that race but
was it like a hematoma I mean what do we
well no so what happened was like my
shins hurts so bad from having stress
fractures
that's the only way I could continue on
was I taped it so I wasn't doing the
flexor motion that that activates your
shins
so I taped my ankles and my shins up and
I got that from because of my throat
hell week they were all good let me go
back to you know train anymore right so
I literally went through all the buds my
last seal training with stress fractures
and shin splints and how I did it was I
would take my ankles all the way up to
my calf every morning so for the first
hour the pain was excruciating but what
happened is my feet would go numb and I
did that every single day for six months
whoa that's how I got through my third
hell because I was so broken from the
first two that the commander said hey
the CEO said this year last time we're
sitting you through so that's how I got
the idea to do that so with the right
and people may listen to this and say
this guy is sadistic he's crazies know
if you know how I came up you realized I
was just a scared kid that found Drive
and passion to be something much better
than what he thought he was that's all
it is
self-talk and visualization of two keys
to my success I believed for that last
time 19 miles I was indestructible
because I took myself in that chair
crapping up my back peeing blood in my
leg shin splint stress fractures I used
all that for motivation versus
negativity
I use a fear motivation I said to myself
who on this earth would still be going
right now you are you are you got to be
the hardest on the planet is it true I
don't give at that time it got me to the
finish line of that race I believed it
I believe it today I believed it enough
to where my body said he's not going to
stop and that's I took all the negative
things I need to go to the hospital this
and that and I uses all who the hell
could even get on that chair you did
who the hell would even think about
taping stress fractures up you did all
those things I'd use for motivation rule
number eight accept your journey what's
the point of living you know a lot of us
go through our daily day routine kiss
the wife kiss the husband whenever
you're doing and that's our life you
know I believe everybody's put on this
earth for a journey and everybody's
journey is different but most people
don't know take their journey they try
and take an easier path so that's what
it's all about you gotta accept your
journey a lot of times your journey
sucks but that's what you gotta do rule
number nine gives back
it's always about giving back you know
God gave me a gift you know a gift to
kind of achieve what I need to achieve
you know a strong mind and if I can kind
of relay that message to these young
kids young young men and women it's just
uh have these events around it's just
this helps them out ups and growing kids
the mentors nowadays yes and and they
hear a positive message from people who
don't have much know that hey I can do
it yes that was all about you'll need
much to you'll become a lot rule
important test your limits
I started doing this triathlons and
endurance sports ultra runs just to test
my soul to see them about to see in the
hundred and fifty mile race at Mile 75
when I feel really bad that's when you
know that's the only time you can find
out what the human body is all about
what you're made of
to find out limits to my self limits to
the human soul and every day I'm trying
to see if I have limits
[Music]
I run anywhere from 125 150 in a week so
I'll try and put in about 450 miles a
month usually every day I wake up at 3
o'clock in the morning and I run
anywhere from 10 to 15 miles in the
morning and then I live about 25 miles
from work so I get my bicycle commute
into work do a normal work day at lunch
time around noon I'll run again and you
where from 5 to 8 miles whatever maybe
come back work and around 5:30 I'll ride
back home 25 miles on my bike if I'm
feeling good and I'm gonna get more
miles I'll get off the bike and do like
a short 3 or 4 or 5 mile run that's my
everyday life so I don't this train like
an hour or so I train until something is
uncomfortable and then actually know who
you are the only easy day was yesterday
it just never ends I mean I've done some
races where you're on a one-mile track
and you're a run for 48 hours straight
so imagine running for 48 hours running
one-mile track it's not like you're
sleeping you're you're running for 48
hours seven miles you can get I want to
talk about mine torture
my life doesn't have a finish line so
when I cross the finish line of the
Ironman doesn't matter because I know
that you know two or three weeks from
now I'll be doing something else if I
might bite through more pain
[Music]
I believe you know everything I try to
do is kind of define by excellence but I
don't think I ever reach excellence
myself because I have my standards of my
life I'm really high so I don't ever
reach it but I tried to every day
you have to be a good individual first
before you can be a good team player I
know for a fact how bad he'll dig it I
went through a couple times it's
probably the most brutal military
training anybody go through so everybody
to my left and everybody to my right
they've been through this so I know
milli you know these individuals are
extremely hard and when stuff gets bad
and know in each situation I know these
guys have my back
[Music]
I've done a lot of things I thought were
impossible nothing's impossible anymore
ruler / 11 choose to be great
my favorite game is swim yeah you know
what saying I mean happy we had little
athletes in my damn family
you know and I was a kid who kind of got
to coming to their bad genes you know I
have all these little sickly issues all
these allergic - I was a little sickly
kid it's funny how when people hear my
story now they want to put a title on me
like I'm superhuman yeah like you had
some special and capability and I loved
it because basically it makes you feel
better by putting a title on me right
you can do - that's right and so base
joints
yes choice yeah it's a horrible choice
man it's a hard choice it's a lot of
suffering involved so for me to get this
dark line through that start line
journey I realize I'm capable mm-hmm so
what happens to this whole process is
the change of the mind mm-hmm it's a
change of the guard mm-hmm
someone once owned my brain I never
owned it yeah
I never even though I had no control you
out your outsourced yes right everybody
had it it was my dad's fault
it was a kids I call me [ __ ] fault my
mom wasn't home fault my soon-to-be
stepdads fault look kids that get rid of
a bus fault
my life was everybody had a piece of my
brain yeah and through this journey of
suffering and the suffering I put it in
because I started finding myself yeah I
started oh no I'm taking back from me
this part of my brain is mine now and so
puzzling back this piece of my brain and
through that I grew confidence in this
process I went from David Goggin I
started forming a guy named Goggins
mm-hmm
I had to really invent I realize I had
to reinvent a whole nother human being
right within myself cause it Who I am
wasn't gonna make it this is not this
guy is not gonna cut it so I think I did
be a guy who can take any kind of pain
any kind of suffering any kind of
torture mentally physically emotionally
spiritually I had had the people who I
visualize everybody that called me
[ __ ] you have to be in a room of
people like this I had to make up these
things in my mind at least I had to
overcome and and I started callous in my
mind do it through a process and it
start with working out the start was
working out I started with doing like if
it started raining outside for instance
my mind was said that man I'm gonna run
mm-hmm if it was three o'clock in the
morning to start reading outside my mind
said you gotta go get up and go really
you have to because I was fighting this
other person so you essentially tried to
do everything you didn't want to do
that's all it was
period on everything I didn't want to do
is what got me to where I'm at today
interest every single thing so where we
find comfort now that's where I started
getting scared now when I started saying
oh it's raining I'm not going out there
no you cannot say that you cannot do
that you you have got to do this the
other so whatever my brain thought I did
the opposite mm-hmm wherever the comfort
was about the opposite direction in over
a period of time boy it calluses this
mm-hmm
out of your mind you start to really
develop a whole nother being rule number
12 be a dreamer I say what if a lot it
sounds corny and it sounds weak but it's
true one of the recruiters said there's
not many black Navy SEALs in fact I was
a 36 african-american seal in history is
in over 60 years because the water you
know all right I mean people get mad at
me it's true just get over it and so I
was like man what story would it be if
my fat dumb lying to be friends with
people insecure ass can overcome this
and that would if mentality like that
that dreamer mentality just would always
fuel me it was just rude man what if I
can be but if I can be a seal man what
if I can go from wearing a quarter of
mile now I run 205 miles what if I can
go but just what if I can go in and what
if how would that feel if I'm graduating
kind of get at that graduation thing I
was talking about to 24th the video I
said then I'll watch this command
officer stood up and he said to the
graduation guys you're graduating buds
like eighteen of them he said we live in
a society where mediocrities often
rewarded and we want to say something
about these men detest mediocrity
and I wanted to be a man that the test
mediocrity rule number 13 finds your why
my biggest advice to give everybody in
the world is like I say we live in an
external world everything is is you got
to see it touch it as it's external if
you can for the rest of your life live
inside of yourself stop listening to
people who are calling you fat gay
transsexual [ __ ] everything that is
makes no sense
all these insecure people put their
insecurities on you you got to flush it
out you got to just be whoever the hell
God or whatever the hell you believe in
if you believe in nothing but yourself I
don't care what it is you're gonna take
everything and throw it away you have to
believe in one thing and that is
yourself and and I'm not saying don't
believe in God of what you believe in
but right now for you to find greatness
in yourself you're not going to find it
by looking in a book or by even hearing
me I may give you the spark but you've
got to go inside yourself to find it and
that means you gotta be quiet shut the
[ __ ] up go in a room stop talking search
your soul search your mind search your
abilities and you'll find it but if
you're not looking for it you won't find
it so you got to go start your journey
and the journey starts with you finding
why the hell am I here on this planet
earth why am I here and if you don't
know that you will live the rest your
life searching always asking the
question why
rule number 14 keep getting up growing
up being the kid I was I found strength
in different movies yeah so I come home
in one movie I found a lot of strength
as funny as it may seem but I visualized
this scene
I do it today during the pull up record
if 4030 pull-ups in the last time I did
actually got it to be three times I
played one song for 17 hours pretty much
is from this movie Rocky one round 14
mm-hmm I related to the person in the
movie mm-hmm but just the one scene when
Apollo's beaten Iraqi he falls in the
corner and everybody in rocky and Apollo
turns around arms up
because I got this guy he turns around
not knowing that Rocky's trying to get
up up off the canvas
Mickey st. Mickey's this trainer saying
stay down or everybody saying you did
good you did good you had 14 rounds with
the champ rockin in here he got up and
was dicks in my mind today seen it right
now when he got up a power starts to
turn around to see the aftermath of what
is destroyed and he did not expect to
see what he saw right and what I see of
the whole movie I see a power crease
face yeah fear crept in yes it I said to
myself as a young kid I want to be that
mm-hmm I don't need to win
I don't need trophies I need people like
me I just want what he has
yeah a fictional character whatever the
hell was I want that and I visualized
that and I want to become the guy who
can get off the canvas and look at
somebody who beat the fish out of him
life what's about life right now in life
even life itself pushed her head down
towards a vinyasa yeah this is not going
to stop so that mentality became what I
wanted nice and that's how it started
with that visualization of the canvas
mm-hmm and all I got to do is just keep
getting up rule number 15 develop a
crazy work ethic that's her negatives
into positives so I would I would take
like who would even think about doing
this so I would sit in my couch saying
who at 297 who can't swim that great who
scary the water
we had the balls kind of balls to man up
quit a job and go and it put everything
on himself so it's how I started talking
to myself and put myself in a whole
different category and that was fueled
me the next day and I just kept using
that as fuel and fuel no one would do
this no want to do this you're the best
around you're the best
never live and I had the guys kept
fueling me with the with the right kind
of message that I needed to hear that
was never telling myself
if through time it became reality to
myself so you start out on the first day
and then you start running again the
second day yeah second day were right
back after again but I started realizing
I can't run that far right so what I did
was I became damn near professional
cyclist with the miles I put it on the
bike so I never whenever I watch TV I
had to be doing something so I was
riding the bike
I ordered bike a lot to it to lose the
first initial kind of weight cause it
took my bones were just hurting so bad
my body's just broken and I learned to
get over that also and I try to swim a
lot I went a great swimmer but putting
fins on kind of equalize my body I
wasn't so negative buoyant so I started
fitting a whole bunch and I spent hours
in the pool hours in the pool trying to
get more and more comfortable not
because I was going underwater I was so
scared of the water that I had to live
in the water I had to become one with
the water so going to the pool used to
scare me so I went to pool an awful
awful lot and then the bike got easier I
was able to run more I went from like
one mile well Maya's a great
accomplishment two miles and then from
two to three was a bigger then I went
from three to six and then like they
have a warning order that they get
people to get ready for buts
and the whole thing was running six
miles five days a week and that was my
goal and so I just kept I failed I go
back to scratch I used some positive
motivation I have like one day when I
back defeated but I started realizing
this a part of the process this a part
of the journey
I had to realize this is part of my
process versus just saying like I used
to
I'm just not good enough if I'm not good
enough we always say this I'm it's not
good enough and then we try something
else I'm gonna make myself good enough
and that became my mentality I'm gonna
make myself good enough and so I
misunderstood a lot but that's that's
all it came down to I made myself good
enough and the days I couldn't run that
far the next week I would do two a days
so on the running if I ran a quarter a
mile I wait a couple hours it haunt me
bother me I try to run a half mile next
time same day you can do more than this
if I had to walk had to walk it just
became just a process of grinding and
grinding and grinding is not even a good
word for it
it's not even a good word for it and
just just going further and further and
then when I got through running I go to
the bike I go to the pool if I got tired
somewhere my legs are tired I go to the
gym and I developed this crazy workout
where I was doing volume like two-three
hundred reps of like very lightweight
people are saying how you know how come
you have any like loose skin my workout
routine in the gym became sick it became
sick I was just doing two 300-400 reps
on like chest just like for one simple
exercise the best press and a racket get
back on it just rep it out trying to
burn as many calories I can't build that
muscle mass and I just became just
became possessed with it rule number 16
attack you once said that if you were
growing up in this generation that you
would have a field day because you would
take their souls what did you mean by
that the younger generation quits not
everybody so I got it I got put that
people get their butt hurt so not
everybody most of this generation quits
the second they get talked to you did
this wrong you did this wrong or they
get yelled at it's so easy to be great
nowadays because everybody else is most
people are weak this this is a softened
generation so if you have any mental
toughness any of any ability be of any
fraction of self-discipline the ability
to not want to do it but still do it
people have a hard thing understand I
hate to run and what makes me so crazy
it doesn't anymore
tickle why did you run if you hate it
what are you talking about I don't want
to take showers and eat either I hate
that too that the whole that's a life
man that and it wasn't until I changed
that mentality that I became somebody I
hated going to school so I guess what I
was dumbest that's what will one plus
one is two but if you can get through to
doing things that you hate to do
on the other side is greatness that's
what people are saying by me running
I am callous in my mind I'm not training
for a race I'm training for life I'm
training for the time when I get that
two o'clock in the morning call that my
mom is dead or something happens tragic
in life I don't fall apart I'm training
my mind and my body my spirit so it's
all one so I can handle what life is
gonna throw at me because the life I've
lived it throws a whole bunch at you and
if you're not physically immensely
prepared for that you're just gonna
crumble and you're good for nobody
talked to me about what it takes to be
on one side of a door in Iraq or
anywhere knowing on the other side of
the door people who are not afraid of
you they're ready for you to come in and
you still have and they have guns and
you still have to breach that door
that's a great question it that's a very
scary situation when you are on one side
of the door and your mind is racing
because on the other side of that door
it could be no one it could be four guys
with four ak-47s that that door are you
about to open can be booby-trapped so
once you open it boom your legs are gone
so there's a thousand things you think
about when you're the first guy second
guy third guy getting ready to go in a
room and flooding and that's why I talk
about the warrior mentality and that's
why so many people are lost when I start
talking you have the right you're lucky
that you don't have to think like
warriors think you're very privileged I
chose this world to be a warrior and I
would choose it again if I came back to
this world but the mentality of a
warrior is very different than normal
mentality you must be that person on
that door Oh get ready to open it
thinking to yourself if I die so be it
the only way you can go in that door is
no there's a great chance you're gonna
die like being a seal you train with
live ammo you jump on an airplane
everything you do
you could die so to be a warrior why
people don't understand me I'm glad you
don't understand me Merry Christmas good
on you
because being a warrior takes a whole
different mindset a whole different
mindset to know that there's a great
chance I may not be didn't look like I
was in for 21 years I'm lucky I'm very
lucky that I'm alive able to talk to you
able to still run but when you sign up
with a downline to be a set like a seal
your mentality changes I may not live
you got accept that and that's the
mentality you have and that's what makes
you a warrior if you're scared to die
you're a bad warrior I hate it jumping
out of airplanes I hated shooting guns I
hate it the job as a Navy SEAL but I did
it because I wanted to change myself
everything I do I'm not really
comfortable doing but if you choose to
go that route to go be a Navy SEAL you
might as well go be the hardest in the
world because if you're choosing to do
something you have two routes you can go
there and be a little a little weak
person and get through barely and that's
your reputation or you can go through
the hardest guy you can possibly be a
natural reputation so my whole thing is
if you're gonna choose to open that door
in Iraq or Afghanistan open them and go
in hard because they're gonna remember
you by slowly opening and peeking in so
if you're gonna open it and you made
them on to open it don't crack it open
open the door go in that's with life if
you choose to do if you choose to do
something attack it because they're
gonna remember you as not attacking it
so I want to be remembered you can hate
me but one thing you can't say about me
I didn't attack it so that's them attire
you have if you're gonna do something
you might as well attack it because you
do it anyway right do use that in
civilian life like do you still employ
the I'm in attack and I'm gonna take
their souls like how does that play out
in a non-combat zone
it still works for me in in life as far
as attacking things because uh no matter
what I want to you no matter what Avenue
I choose I want to be the very best and
the very best may not be I'm number one
the very best is did I leave everything
inside of me out there so attacking it's
not like I want to win this or win that
or be the best the best is I'm running
against myself and everything I do and
and that's and that's what I attack I
attack myself I'm always questioning
myself I'm always holding myself
accountable rule number 17 take
accountability as a leader the one thing
I did horribly wrong on my second
platoon I actually started developing
the attitude towards people within at Pt
hard mm-hmm who didn't get after who
work because I know I took it all the
way to limit and so I should've been a
better leader by knowing okay no I'm not
every wants to be David Goggins now
maybe wants to go for a hundred miles
everybody everyone's God guys if my
skill says yeah right you know maybe you
know when I go to the gym whatever the
gym is fine but it was just a different
standard so I couldn't take away my
standard for the whole about the group
interesting I looked at people I you man
you know you yeah you ain't tryin give
more you so my mentality I weren't a
good leader and I look back on that now
trust me a lot of people get other
things differently I'm taking kind of
duty for I could've done different good
I looked at that but so my mentality
from a weak kid became super hard like
beyond hard next-level hard and um but
that's what I was getting myself into
as a leader I should have stepped back
and run say these are your expectations
David Goggins right what are we here to
accomplishment it's important to lead by
example if I say lead by example if
you're the leader is to loan this job on
the planet and if you do it you have to
be up early you leave late you got do
the sucky jobs at least that's how I
look at it you got to be the man that is
always the person who's being held
accountable to the highest standard
mm-hmm and not expecting your people do
anything that you're not going to do
twenty times more than they are even
when even when you're the leader mm-hmm
and and I and it's all about
accountability for yourself in
leadership roles not about being pissed
because people aren't doing what you
doing mm-hmm they brought different
skill sets rule number 18 braked the
limits
[Music]
when you think that you are done you
only forty percent into what you're
biased capable of doing and that's just
a limit there that we pour herself
[Music]
got our leader of 150 mile coming in
[Applause]
you never get really know how I feel I
never really tell you the truth I'm
always gonna feel good I want to feel
and show you no weakness
congratulations buddy thanks a lot man
cutter 50-mile champion first place new
course record way to go graduation I'm
never happy and satisfied with one thing
I do is always a continuous journey in
all my races there's never in it's kind
of fallen in together it's like one big
journey that that won't end i guy rule
number 19 do yoga do you ever do yoga
all the time man all the time and I if I
were to tell somebody one thing right
now man that's so as muscle and getting
that hip flexor opened up because we're
all stressed too freaked out it was it's
almost worse than others it changed my
life I'm one of those I've drawn on too
much about yoga I'm like one of those
vegans it's like you got to do it man
right try I get it knowing like a
born-again Christian or something it's
like I'm getting that way now man I
guess no way now for anybody does
anything hard like you know if you do
anything like with weightlifting types
or martial arts types where it's just
everything's explosion its lifting it's
heavy it's push push push right yoga
just will bounce you're out yeah well
yeah really well man and there's all
these people that resist it like there
was some article recently that was
something along the lines of hot yoga is
just trendy nonsense I read that and
then even in the article it talked about
that there might be some benefits in
terms of like the strengthening your
arteries and they didn't even mention
heat shock proteins there's a study
going on right now I believe it's at
Harvard right one of my friends was
telling me about it where they're
they're trying to find the benefits of
90 minute hot yoga classes because they
think it might mirror the observed
benefits of sauna which they already
know for a fact has big benefits because
of your body producing heat shock
proteins to deal with the heat right I
thought about that sauna in here man I
go enough or all the time well no one
can tell me he doesn't work that's big
it's proof positive change my life that
it wasn't a medication or this or a
dress it was stretching yeah it was yoga
stretching all that stuff combined
change
rule number 20 embrace the suck so when
things hit you in life that you're
afraid of or you're not good at the
first thing you're gonna say to yourself
is why am I here anyway this isn't for
me the water is too cold the sun's too
hot I'm getting up too early why am I
doing this to myself that's what the
normal mind says I had to start training
my mind to think about how can I get
through this not giving myself a way out
never give myself creating the wall
around all the ways out in my mind and a
slowly starts to build this wall so my
mind knew this is not gonna give himself
a way out of here in my first home we
got a huge setback I was broken my legs
were broken I had double pneumonia I got
rolled back to day one week one of Navy
SEAL training I got through that second
hell week during that second hell week I
actually broke my knee I continued to
limp around for a couple weeks I
couldn't make it anymore got rolled back
to day one week one I'll never forget
standing there in front of captain Bowen
he was a co in charge of Navy SEAL
training at the time and he had no mercy
on anybody if he believed in managing
your expectations I wouldn't be here
today he challenged me again I was
challenged my whole life not by the
mindset of managing expectations by
exceeding expectations not by managing
them I'm standing there with crutches
I'm sitting in his office he looks at me
he goes jogging this year last time
we're gonna push you through Navy SEAL
training this would be your third hell
week in one year we're not gonna put you
through a 40 so this is your last time
I'm saying thinking how am I gonna get
through this I'm badly jacked up my legs
are broken my knee is messed up
and he goes 'i have a couple of months
to get better a couple of months isn't
gonna do it i won't get healed up a
couple of months but i realized i'm
going to get through this I'm gonna find
a way to get through it cuz why I put
barriers in my mind so my third hell
week I went in there with pretty much I
would put a black sock on first I would
get duct tape and I duct-taped my ankles
all the way up to my calf every single
morning then I put another black sock
over it and what that did that prevented
me from moving my ankle so I didn't
really I wasn't flexing my shin as much
now I started running with just my hip
flexors in this hell week it was a bad
hill we had a guy died on Thursday
morning of hell week I went on to become
a Navy SEAL greatness is not something
that you meet once it's something that
you meet thousands of times in your life
and you don't reach it if you're not
constantly in constant pursuit of
greatness so if my mom would say right
now I'm great
I just lost we're gonna grow we're not
gonna triple down on our strengths we're
not gonna do that crap we're gonna work
on our weaknesses so we grow we need
friction to do that without friction
there's no growth without friction this
confusion confusion is David gagas how
did you become who you are today I put a
bunch of friction in my life and I grew
that's how I did it you want to get
really tough it's a lifestyle instead of
hitting that snooze button in the
morning and not making your bed not
cleaning your house you don't get this
news button you get up you don't want to
go run you go run you don't want to go
swim you go swim you wanna make your bed
you make your bed
you know where a kid in your house and
clean your house you don't want to study
study that's how you start to callus
your mind so that became my life if you
say you're gonna wake up at 4 o'clock in
the morning to go run wake up at 4
o'clock and it's gonna suck it's not
gonna be fun do something that sucks
every single day of your life that's how
you grow embrace the Sun rule number 21
change your life I never forget one time
during a basketball game
there was this coach mr. trout he knew
me when I was a kid in that school I was
a third grade getting set back mr. trout
always loved me this white man loved his
dad I mean I don't know why you did but
he was my JV basketball coach my
sophomore year the visiting team was at
our home stadium was at the end the game
and the visiting team who started
chanting I was the only black person in
the whole dadgone stadium they started
chanting [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] that's all
I remember at that time of my life
that's all I remember
but not 42 years old I can look back on
that time with clear eyes and a clear
mind and see what mr. child did for me
he went in that locker room when I was
crying upset and he cried with me this
white man cried with me but that time on
I didn't see that I saw was red I saw
hate this whole town hated me
everybody's against me my mind lost it
and for some reason I couldn't sleep on
my bed until this day I don't know why
the floor felt so comfortable and at 22
21 years old I went from 175 pounds to
297 pounds fat out of shape
insecure I was everything everybody said
I was going to be that's what I was and
it makes you feel like [ __ ] so I got job
spraying for cockroaches at night I'm
not saying it's a bad job but I didn't
want to do it so for about six months I
went around to your local eateries
spraying for cockroaches this one night
I came home the first thing I do I walk
in my living room turn the TV on first
thing I do and then walk back to the to
take a shower and I was listening to the
TV I was I was trying to take a shower
this day changed my life it held me
accountable for what I wasn't facing in
life they're going through Navy SEAL
training and I sat down I I came out of
the shower and I sat down something
brought me back to sit down and watch
these guys going through hell I saw a
ton of them quittin ringing the bell
ringing the bell means you quit Navy
SEAL training
I saw him putting their helmet down this
went on through the whole show and it
finally got to the very end there's
about 15 to 20 guys to the very end and
this one statement changed my life they
were all sitting there and they're
dressed whites and this CEO this
commanding officer stands up in front of
these men and he looks sharp and he I
could tell you stood for something and
he said we live in a world where
mediocrity is often rewarded these men
up here detest mediocrity when you hear
a statement like that it forces you to
think about yourself I wouldn't even
mediocre I wasn't anything
under the bottom of the barrel of life I
chose the four-lane highway for my life
the easy route the route that has gas
stations throughout the house signs and
say 20 miles to the next service stop
all this I chose that about most of us
choose the four-lane highway when I was
born
it was also a shovel over here in the
corner
laughter no one wants to go into the
shovel they were to choose the four lane
in Howard estin that's a nice wrap the
shovel means you're gonna hurt the
several means you're gonna suffer this
summer means are gonna hit Rock a lot of
time and we all know what digging
through Rock is like when you hit a root
you gotta get some more tools out if I
had no more tools just a shovel I was
choosing the four-lane highway this is
my decide to pick up that shovel that we
all decide not to take I had to make a
change in my life so I say you know what
I have to join the military now we're on
a Navy SEAL training became the only
person I believe in history to go
through three Negi steel helmets in one
year rule number 22
don't be your own worst enemy with your
learning disability with your dad
beating you screaming at you emotionally
challenging your mind with the racism
you dealt with with the different
struggles you felt with bullies what was
the shot the hardest obstacle to
overcome
from up until about 15 16 the hardest
obstacle was myself I started realizing
more and more and more that all these
people were gone what was haunting me
was me
I can't control my dad I can't control
the people calling me [ __ ] I can't
control all these things but they were
things that kept me down it started to
become my reality my reality was what
they made it out to be and I became the
most important conversation you ever had
with your life you know in your life
isn't help yourself mm-hmm
and my conversation was absolutely
horrifying what were you saying to
yourself I'm dumb
I'm nobody my dad I mean my dad was
great in mental warfare a drunk insecure
man hmm
will make everybody around him feel like
hell yeah because he wants to give you
no power and that's why he was so mean
and my mom and myself and my brother
because he didn't want anybody to get
above him mm-hmm
you want to keep you down low so when
you're growing up with all this stuff
all this hate and it wasn't the beatings
I kept the beatings all day it was a
mental torture so when at a young age
your your parents put a dialog in you of
confidence or your nobody mm-hmm so that
voice in my head was I'm a loser and
then it was confirmed when I got in
school and in third grade I was falling
behind they want to put me in a special
school yeah you know with kids who can't
learn right then was confirmed look you
know what my dad was saying so that
confirmed it then I started cheating so
I realize you know what I'm taking the
easy way out again yeah it starts no
bond for there now the kids are calling
me a [ __ ]
mm-hmm but it wasn't all the kids so
what happens is you start to get this
picture that everybody hates you because
your reality becomes so so big that you
know you can't see the clear picture it
might have been three or four I see
doing it over and over but it was the
whole town yeah everybody hated me
so start world hates me that's right
yeah and that's when they that's what
became toxic and that is where I became
my worst enemy rule number 23 be
relentless
hello everybody it's Groundhog Day again
for David Gardens if you pan it down
here you see about three o'clock in the
morning and there's not a car or person
in sight if you pan over here it's the
same thing not a car or a person in
sight people don't know where I find my
strength that where I get my strength I
get it from a lot of places though right
now this morning I'm getting it from
there's none of them that's up there's
not a car there's not a person
everybody's in their bed sleep
reading that is a Monday hate is a
Monday and I'm loving it I'm loving that
we're buyers getting weaker I'm getting
stronger it's not about the running the
swimming to push up to sit ups it's
about what those things do for your
mentality you don't get better on a
daggone couch you get better by coming
out here and getting after every daggone
day rule number 24 find your motivation
I was obsessed with rocky rocky one in
particular and when I was a kid I come
every day and I watched this show rocky
and I was fast forward with the little
VHS tapes to round 14 round 14 me up
like nobody's business why this song
came on right so when I bought the
pull-up record I listened to the song
for 17 hours it's two minutes and 13
seconds and I'm able to visualize and
dream like nobody's business and I know
that I can create a vision that many
people can't and I work for so the
vision I had was when Apollo Creed beat
the rocky beat the stuffing he's kept
fighting he was a dumb fighter couldn't
read couldn't tell me couldn't read
couldn't write just punchy everything
about him and rocky beaches are probably
stomach he's in the corner but I was
saying stays off down and him getting up
him getting up Apollo Creed raised his
arms up and turn around thought he won
the fight he turns around and sees this
guy getting up and it was the face of
Apollo Creed that changed my life the
face of Apollo Creed it was like just by
them getting up not winning just by him
getting the up Apollo Creed was his
champ his best rocky had taken his soul
had literally taken his soul his head
goes down he looks at my could what the
are you I wanted to be that not rocky I
want to be the guy that people looked at
I don't keep you've liked me or didn't
like I don't care but I said this was
gonna keep coming after whatever is in
front of them I wanted that
I wanted that I wanted that worse than
anything in the world
so that is I kept picturing me falling
down and getting up in every mother call
me [ __ ]
I was dumped even myself even myself I
wanted to feel something besides two
feet I wanted to just go to distance and
that going a distance pushed me to a
point of where now I go way past a
distance rule number 25 don't make
excuses was the greatest lesson your mom
taught you growing up
honestly the greatest lesson she had
taught me is a lesson that she did she
doesn't know how much she taught me
because she wasn't much in the teaching
mode my dad took her soul but what I did
as a young kid is I observed
everybody I wasn't really smart in the
books yeah if I was real smart when it
came to life yeah and I was able to sit
back and watch her mistakes I was able
to see how she struggled through life
and how I don't want to struggle through
life and I was able to see she never
picked me up
the biggest thing she did for me and
this is honest-to-god truth and she
doesn't know she did it without busting
my ass but I would fail you know when I
was at the bottom of the sewer she never
picked me up she never gave me that
cookie and said hey son you know it's
going to be okay no she didn't have time
for that
and sometimes she gets upset when I talk
about my past because it paints her out
to be not the best mom if I had any kind
of mom in that kind of environment I
would have never made it mmm because she
forced me for ever reason she forced me
did you better figure this out or are
you gonna be a statistic mom and this is
something she didn't sit down and tell
me I realized this this is the world
that is in front of me and what most
people do is they see this world and
they look at it as an excuse to get out
of it you know I started looking at it
as this is the ultimate training ground
for the rest of my life
I have all these valuable lessons
because if you look out of the world
right now today it's not a nice place
I'm very prepared for it yeah you are
not prepared for it I'm prepared for all
the failure coming my way I'm prepared
for everything my way and that's the
biggest lesson that she taught me by not
teaching me mm-hmm
by never saying it's gonna be okay
matter of fact she told me exact
opposite life sucks
rule number 26 become obsessed Stephen
Sal Joe was my recruiter I walked in way
97 he looked at me strangely and I said
I wanna be a seal and lucky enough the
guy looked at me and said let's see what
we can do
he waved me I weigh 260 pounds
overweight the guy said man there's a
program that's about to end that you can
go and if you make it through buds you
think Oh active duty right and you'll be
a seal if not you come to home right
sounds like yeah so anyway you gonna
make out lose 160 pounds less than 3
months how did you lose the weight in
three months you just run your ass off I
couldn't run the first thing about it
was so I said it myself
I'm about four miles my first run off
the gate I'm gonna run for miles I ran a
mile about a quarter of a mile walked
home sound the cows depressed I said man
there's no way I can do this but what I
realized though is I wasn't gonna give
up had already given up too many times
and I thought about how would I feel at
50 years old if you gave him now if I
gave up now I'm not to have you know so
I kept all their stuff in my mind you
know basically I started becoming
obsessed hmm I slowly it didn't happen
that night on the couch right over a
period of time I started becoming
obsessed with studying with weight with
being somebody was making people who
thought was gonna be nothing kind of
like feel like I became obsessed with
you have to make this right in other
persons could do it yourself so I became
obsessed with just being obsessed rule
number 27 open the door before I started
race
I actually imagine myself going through
all those checkpoints
math and all these different emotions
and things I'm gonna go through so when
that happens it just flows all this
imagery is so important in life if you
can see yourself doing something you can
do it if you can't see yourself doing it
usually you can't achieve it everybody I
get into I hit a wall in a race that's
so long if you hit several walls and
every time you hit a wall it's a big
deciding factor in that race or in your
life if you're not running and you have
a decision to make if you can stop at
that wall you can go parallel left or
parallel right you're looking for that
door and when you get to the door you
have another decision to make
should I open it or should I keep it
closed if you keep it closed you made
the decision to quit if you open that
door you made a decision to carry on and
continue on with your journey or your
mission whenever you're on and I always
open that door because once you open the
door and you go through it your mind
resets and it gets you a few more miles
I came describe it to you how how you
feel when you know you're gonna complete
the hardest thing they're done your life
the second you realize not gonna give up
your body gets back in tune again and
you're ready to go I have those mental
blocks all through the race but that's
when I smile - I signed up for that race
to see what kind of season I'm gonna
make and that's why I do it and usually
it's the season to keep on going forward
I have to experience life and that's how
I experience life rule number 28 gives
back but I started getting these emails
from people saying hey you know what you
changed my life that part changed my
life that part of your story changed my
life and because I have so many
different parts of my life that so many
people resonate with different spots
maybe it's doing B Spartan maybe it's
the bullying part maybe it's a learning
disability point maybe it's the abusive
parent part whatever it may be
right so many people draw from my story
I started getting these emails and I was
like kind of man you know I'm a big
believer in something more powerful than
me I don't know what it is but I'm not
the end-all so I was like I gotta start
doing more hmm if I'm touching these
people's lives
a few people hearing right maybe
I need to go out here and do some more
God put me in a very interesting spot of
life where he made hell my teacher mmm
he made hell my teacher a lot of people
don't understand that so I'm trying to
give people a different thought process
of life where failure hell
disappointment discomfort is a great
learning tool and many people don't
understand that and a lot of people
won't won't even understand this
interview when we get done with it but
if these few moments in life that you
have like for me I always talked about
it
rocky one round 14 that 1/2 minute in 13
second clip of rocky getting up when
Apollo knocked him down that one clip
when I was going through a very bad time
of my life I saw what I wanted to be
there wasn't a guy that won the Wonder
guy that won everything he did it was a
guy that kept getting up after being
knocked down so I realized if that 2
minutes and 13 seconds changed my life
so I was I saw something that I needed
to be in the world I was living in maybe
my story will give someone - 2 minutes
and 13 seconds they need to change their
life these are people live in a very
comfortable place that's fine don't
listen to me a lot of people are looking
for that 2 minutes and 13 seconds mm and
I might be that person and I believe
that we're all were all teachers
we're all teachers and if you don't
learn something and gets back we got
like what you learned yeah what's the
point of living you're wasting yeah your
ways that you have all this knowledge of
what you learn some people might think
you're crazy
some people may you know may put a title
on you but it's it is you know if
there's a few people who are like you
know what I need to hear that mm-hmm so
you have to put yourself out there
rule number 29 commit is fully I often
talk about taking souls
this morning this person I usually train
alone first abundant Romani I said 5:15
this morning comes this doors coming in
this way and the person calls and said
hey why don't we do it tomorrow
taking souls is when I told them I'm
gonna run 15 today and I run with you
again tomorrow
that's what taking solace is about don't
worry about the elements and what's
going on you gotta get out there and get
it and that's taking souls and obviously
he wasn't the only one that fell about
taking the day off because the storm is
coming here right now and there's not a
soul out here but me rule number 30 find
your purpose everybody's journey is
different everybody's journey is
different I was on a journey to see who
David Goggins was and that journey took
me in some of the hardest areas a human
being can even imagine and right now at
41 I'm the happiest person on the planet
because you know I had to climb Mount
Everest several times just to look down
on my life to see what hell I came from
and that's what kept me going through
all this stuff like I am vision myself
going through like when I was a young
kid and they called me [ __ ] all the
time that got my dad beat the hell out
of me and I was had no self-esteem I had
this vision of if I can make it to where
I want to go imagine when I look back on
my damn life how proud I will be and now
I'm here and I'm able to look back on
this life I lived that many people will
never understand because why when you're
passionate they think you're crazy and
you can't even explain to people why
you're doing and why you did what you
did because you found your purpose and
once you find your purpose you can't
really explain it to normal people
because they don't understand passion
because they live everyday life just
going not really finding their purpose
so I become a foreign language to people
to think so they put me a category for
this crazy
no-no-no I'm passionate I found my
purpose in this life
rule number 31 outwork everyone where I
got my work ethic from was the hours I
had to spend learning this when you sit
down and you're not smart you have a
disability yeah and you still want to be
at the top of your class I didn't want
to get by what I realized that I can
learn the hard work and I can beat the
valedictorian in school if I got put in
ten hours more a day than he does you
know what kind of strength comes from
that when you're sitting down that guy
that that valedictorian study for an
hour
and you know I caught you I caught you
and I am dumb but I have the work ethic
to catch you that's where David gagas
got really invented yeah was at a
kitchen table with 20 spiral notebooks
that were empty and then three months
later yeah they were full and you can go
through that too I have me in my storage
and you're going through these power
notebooks of your life and you're like
this is how I learned this is
unbelievable there's no miles it's not
about the models is that having a
discipline every day they say for me to
learn this one math problem it's gonna
take me ten hours and that's where it
you realize do hard work you can do you
can outwork anybody how bad as they are
but that's the part people don't want to
dive into rule number 32 find your inner
strengths well there's something that I
invented a long time ago and when you
have nothing to draw from I was able to
find strength in every molecule of this
earth I'm able to be in a room with
nothing with no motivation no
inspiration nothing and find it so what
I did in those situation was I invent
this thing called taking souls when
everybody's off up and you're exhausted
and you're weak and you're tired and
you're looking around and everybody
looks as bad as you or even worse I'm
like you know what I want to now make a
statement
it's the perfect time to make a
statement to make a statement to let you
know where your life ends and mine
begins and so the statement there is I
muster up every bit of strength from
their looks on their faces and how they
feel and how I'm gonna now from my
childhood where I came from how's the
bottom of the barrel I'm now amongst all
these uncommon people I'm now going to
now make you feel like you're common so
I used their their sadness their
weakness their parts of their life oh
god this sucks I'm like all poopy pants
too messed up I use that for my strength
and I have this moment of like let's say
we're in the sand we're running or
whatever I will do a surge I would do
something everybody how's he doing this
and from that that look on their face
that feeling of God man this guy must be
something something special it didn't
services me further and further and
faster and harder for a long time so
it's energies everywhere but the thing
is it's so loud that that that voice in
your head of pain and suffering and
discomfort and I don't want to do this
is so loud that you're unable to really
calm it down it's okay
there's something here it's a patient
calm that you have to bring your
substitute I know I have something here
but that voice is so powerful that it's
once you just let's leave right we're
done we're done it spazzes you out and
you want to go forces saying let's take
a second hang on
before we [ __ ] out hang on and in
that moment you can think clearly and
find that strength out there for you
rule number 33 never gives up my first
time going through buds I got the whole
week I'm stress fractures double
pneumonia
I get rolled back day one week one
second time going through buds I
actually fractured my patella before I
got in hell week made it through hell
weep with a fractured patella went two
weeks after hell week and then cuz why I
didn't want to get rolled back to day
one week one I couldn't keep up with the
class got rolled back to day one week
one after hell week and then I went
through my third time and I graduate
that class we had a guy died in that
throat hell week class 235 so that's
kind of how it happened
rule number 34 face your obstacles I
don't like getting more conference it
starts with yourself man you got to
start diving into those things that you
are afraid of you don't gain confidence
by going to the spot that makes you feel
good it could be a false reality in this
second life gives you that challenge all
you want to do is go back to what makes
you confidence or what gave you
confidence is that happy spot no what
gives you confidence where gave me
confidence was spending years at a
kitchen table trying to learn how to
read and write all my own realizing I
can't learn the way you learn I can't
but I can't learn but gives you
confidence not being afraid it's
overcoming the fear Isis stutter
severely bad so right now I don't know
how many people are gonna watch this
know what gives me confidence is knowing
I'm no longer care you know if I say or
start stuttering to you yeah that's what
gives me compass is facing these things
over coming up if you have not
overcoming them every day but facing
them and face them and face and pretty
like there's no one man this is where
it's at hmm it's not in that comfort
zone it's in the discomfort zone is
where my conference is getting built
mm-hmm that's where it's getting built
but people want to they want to ease
your answer yeah there has to be an
easier way it's not I'm sorry I searched
for my entire life
rule number 35 proves them wrong I'm
really good at creating an enemy I'm
really good at and creating something
that I'm against
I'm also good at if you ever tell me
something that I cannot do I'm gonna let
you know that I'm doing it somehow
somehow you're gonna know one way or
another that I'm doing it it may not be
like in your face it may I may make sure
that I run across the daggone world so
then it's on the news and you turn the
news on so how the hell did he do that I
want to do something that you know I'm
here I'm here
rule number 36 stop looking for finish
lines
that one day
that finish line so a motor finish
that has been
he was horribly missed everything to do
and push slightly beyond
remember this just because you were to
ask
where you can work record very few my
sentimental
no guarantee success never expect
immediate results
stay anyone else to be three cones when
they're you know finished
group victory is your focus to work your
ass off
rule number 37 build yourself up so many
people before I give them a workout
playing the talk about recovery
everybody everybody that hears me speak
they want to go straight to recovery
work out first huh work out first before
you talk to me about recovery how to
recover yet work out first we are always
looking for like whenever I talk to
people people take my words and they
they and they put it in a way to where
they want to feel comfortable this guy
you know they they they want to put you
in a box they want to put a title on you
know you're putting a title on me to
make yourself feel better about yourself
if you read this book of mine you see
where I came from this portion with this
portion was not built this business that
this person was not made by God mm-hmm
this person saw this person was built
I made this person I made this person by
diving in to the insecurities that life
gave me because now they're yours do
yours to own if you're not smart car
yourself dumb it's okay because you are
but take that knowledge you put yourself
down if you're fat car D so fat I used
to be 300 pounds we we want to talk so
soft to ourself we're looking for that
recovery day in that recovery day is
everything in your life everything in
your life is that recovery day we're
looking for it it's not coming it's not
coming get over there recovery day and
that's the mentality I took with me and
what happened through that process was
all the frivolous things of life started
to float away I have to tell people lies
so they would like me hmm cuz I was so
insecure when you start to build
yourself up it start to have the one
thing that we don't have is confidence
yeah real authentic confidence from hard
work everything else goes away you no
longer look to other people for your
self-esteem out - it's like oh yeah
you know no I walk in the room now
I know that hours and years and decades
I put in a date with Gardens
that's something it's not on the wall
it's not a trophy on the wall it's not a
melon on your neck it is actually a
feeling in your heart and people why
don't you ever smile I don't have to
yeah yeah I do have a store look at my
face I'm a very focused person but the
thing I have in my soul in my heart
that's why I need to smile I don't need
to smile I don't need you look at me and
say oh my god you look happy because
helpless aren't happy mm-hmm right we're
giving you something that we think you
want to see I don't do anymore I don't
care how you perceive David Goggins they
get us do my journey I figured out the
one piece I was missing I thought it was
cars I thought it was women I thought it
was my body but I thought I was
everything the one piece I was missing
was me having the courage to face myself
rule number 38 all in your life I wanted
that comfort zone everybody looks for
that pat on the back they don't want to
hear all the bad they want everything
that they're doing right and I realized
that it kept me in this world that's
what kept me in this world I've not
accomplishing anything
so what I did was I became that big bad
nasty that you don't want to walk into
at nighttime I became the roughest
critic in the world on myself and that's
what changed me I literally saw myself
in the mirror I saw the truth for us is
saying you know my dad did this to me
from you know from beating me kids in
school from call me a [ __ ] did this to
me my life to this to me my broken
foundation to this to me I took that and
said you know what well some people may
help this happen but now I have to own
this no one's gonna come back to save me
no one's gonna come back on this couch
and say hey it's okay you're gonna be
okay no I'm not I'm not gonna be okay I
didn't realize I had to take a stand to
make a real stand and it was painful to
look at who I like who I was what the
world and myself created it created a
a very lonely depressed insecure man
that would do anything just to have a
friend and I saw that as very pathetic
when you look at the truth it becomes
very ugly and pathetic rule number 39
seek challenges I started figuring out
going through buds was that the harder
some is the more it was challenged in my
mind so I had to find different ways to
stay in the fight in the stayed in the
fight it got me tougher and tougher and
tougher so I'm actually happy I went
through three whole weeks
I never examined it myself there's a
human being you get examine yourself in
the night and I guess the best place to
examine yourself is Navy SEAL hell week
three times so I got to exam myself a
few times so it started there it started
in hell week and it's still going now at
43 years old
rule number 40 push your limits some of
you just don't get it
I'm not here trying to prove myself how
tough I am I'll try to make you think
I'm trying to give you tools on how to
find more of yourself so why am I in the
water right now at 3 o'clock in the
morning well I was going with you
training I used to hate night swims they
bother me we're not retired I said I'll
never get back in the water get at
nighttime so guess what I'm doing right
now going for a swim at nighttime think
about being better rule number 41 making
new you you know people didn't think I
was human mmm they thought I came from
outer space man from some spacecraft and
landed down here and formed Goggins from
the rocks and the soil of the earth not
know how it is man so I just said yeah
I'm gonna I want to share a secret with
you all we're not talk to people like I
see where I'm at today but I know where
I come from and it's kind of hard to
almost separate that I'm almost not in a
way I'm kissing my own ass but I'm
amazed at what a human being can
actually do so I started talking myself
person is strictly because I know that I
literally made this human being out of
out of just like a whole bunch of scraps
mm-hmm and I wasn't you know I wasn't a
mechanic I wasn't a carpenter so I'd
know how to do anything you know I
wasn't trained and how to build a human
being from nothing you know like my mom
didn't training my dad didn't train me
life in the training well life blood
trail yeah life did train me correction
and I started putting this scrap mill
together like I wonder what happened you
know the first shot try to do is off
stop after a while start learning more
and more and more through pain and
suffering so I learned a norm just
learning so much about stuff before I
knew it man
I built this beautiful car and I'm like
how do I do that and I knew how to knit
and I know how to do it because I have
all the tools do all the failure I went
through trying to build this person
who's mccoggins
rule number 42 get in charge of your
brain I believe that most human beings
are only living at about 40 percent of
their capability so the mind has a
governor like a car if you're driving a
car and the car has a governor on it the
car may say hundred and thirty miles an
hour but the governor set for ninety one
once that governor sets in you get the
ninety one that car starts doing this
the car wants to go the car wants to go
but that factory said uh we're not going
past ninety one we have a factory a nice
governor in our brain and it's a
survival mechanism it protects us from
pain and suffering the second we feel
that our mind says no no this isn't fun
we should back off we should sit down
find something more comfortable and
there's some about the mind the mind has
the tactical advantage over you at all
times at all times of your life the mind
has a tactical advantage over you why is
that it knows that you're afraid of it
knows your insecurities it knows your
deep dark lies and it starts to push you
away from that it pushes you in a
direction that is comfortable the mind
controls everything so what I realized
was that when I was growing up and I was
300 pounds and I got all fat and I got
all insecure
realize that my mind kept taking me in
this direction when things get
uncomfortable for me when I was facing
my insecurities I was facing my fears my
mind said oh no we had the tactical
advantage we just get you separates you
from this feeling this feeling over your
life's all about feelings we want the
happy feeling we don't want that feeling
of this sucks why am I here and you
don't have any choice oh you can't
answer those questions so you leave I
started realizing that if in that moment
you can answer those tough questions and
you are now in charge of your brain
versus your brain ruling you that's
where all that stuff comes from so the
40% rule is all of that you get to 40%
your brain says we're done let's roll
man this is trying to get painful this
is uncomfortable so you sit down you
have to figure out ways and everybody's
different that's how the book kind of
talks about like we all have these
things about you know five steps to this
and four steps to this it's it's not
more than that that's all [ __ ] it's
it's a practice that you have to it's a
habit so if you know that 40 percent I'm
still you know I'm feeling pain at 40
percent feeling pain that's where the 40
percent rule kicks in now it starts okay
I'm feeling pain my mind saying all this
to me it's saying get out of here run
flee the fight-or-flight kicks in okay
we're done we're not good enough it
starts telling you all these things you
start to believe it because the mind
controls all this is the time we have to
gain control back of your mind it's okay
let me see if I can go 45 percent and
once you start giving yourself more and
more hope instead of realizing okay the
mind starts to be okay what are you
doing we're supposed to be going right
and you're going left you start then
controlling your mind start finding more
in you know in yourself and it goes from
40 percent to a lot further than that
but that's the start of it though get to
get to the spot where your mind is
saying stop wherever that is you gotta
get there first and then that's when
that starts to work for you you got to
control yourself in that moment
rule number 43 the
discipline so I prioritized trying to
win the battle in the morning so I
always win the battle of mourning so I
get more anytime every morning I go for
a run that's the first thing I do every
morning haven't taken a day off of
running since December 2016 I've every
day up in the morning so I also stretch
out every day for about two or three
hours every day I've missed two days and
about five and a half six years so
that's just my routine in about four
days a week I'm in the gym hitting the
weights because you know you can't just
be a runner so this is every single day
the the monotony in my life but this is
what builds discipline you know and not
everybody I'm not to tell everybody to
do this but this is my lifestyle this is
how I build self-discipline rule number
44 do the impossible you made this
decision to self publish this book yes
sir right now it's out like number two
or number three on Amazon of all books
all right all right
that just doesn't happen with a
self-published book well that's been the
story of my life I I see something
that's that's quite off quite not the
same and that's what I go for I've just
that this book is exactly who I am as a
person exactly the way I did this book
is harder my almost my entire life
mm-hmm as I see what is not the norm
what's impossible with we know what all
the theorists say you shouldn't be doing
this that's the wrong way to go and I'm
like hmm let me see if I can pull this
off
rule number 45 face the real you a lot
of people can live with themselves look
in the mirror and say I'm okay with
being afraid I'm okay with going on this
easy highway over here the easy highway
has all these signs and directions had
to get somewhere and you have to first
be uncomfortable with how you feel about
yourself with that voice that allow most
like to run away from we all have it we
all have that voice that say hey man you
know you're you're kind of wimping out
right now you kind of be a little punk
right now but I would say okay that's
okay it's okay to tell you little white
lies to ourselves
we first have to face the real you the
real me is David Goggins the real me is
a guy looking at you right now saying I
don't want to be on this show right now
because I used to stutter as a kid and
I'm afraid of that
I'm afraid that here in a second I'm
gonna start stammering a stutter and the
whole world is gonna know that I have
all these issues but that's when I see
right now okay Goggins you got to go on
this show that's Goggins Goggins is
saying okay David Goggins you're a punk
life made you this way we can't live
like this we can't live in fear we can't
live in judgment we can't be afraid of
with the people right now looking at me
saying about me we cannot be afraid of
that
that's Goggins Goggins saying all of you
who don't like me who don't want to in
that person then it comes in but you
have to be David Goggin to say man I'm
afraid of this I'm up here life made me
this way here I stutter I have these
issues with reading and writing and I'm
fat and I'm insecure you have to face
that in that dark room in that dark room
is who you are but in that dark room is
where you have to create another human
being that walks out of that dark room
to face who you are that's the only way
you're gonna get over all those things
you have to create someone else not like
you have two different personalities it
is you but you have to find strength in
that visualization of almost me cracking
out Goggins like almost like that
Superman cape like I'm coming out a
different person a person that doesn't
give up about anything who doesn't care
about being judged who knows I'm weak
who knows I'm afraid who says whatever
you think about me take it whatever I'm
here that's guidance in the dark room
you face yourself you realize you want
to be better you realize you don't want
to be this weak insecure person in the
world he has all these problems that we
all have we all have so also me is a
great platform to tell you who we want
to be now who we are so that's where
that darkroom is rule number 26 be a
good individual first what are
but the some of the most valuable things
you learned in the Navy you can be it
about yourself or you know what some of
the most available things a lot people
say teamwork and stuff like that
teamwork is big but I learned that you
have to be a good individual first you
have to triple down on your weaknesses
because a lot of times like you always
count on your buddy next to you to help
you out sometimes that buddy's not going
to be there you got to make sure that
you are a jack of all trades and a
master of all trades and that's one
thing you got you can have your buddies
back they can have your back but you've
got to work on yourself every single day
rule number 47 do the things you don't
like I'm not a big guy on social media
I'm just not big on that stuff even
today I'm just not a big fan of it ma'am
I'm a big introvert I get a lot of my
strength from being introverted and
going out there and doing what I do is
very all this is a very difficult for me
man oh I don't what do you have like six
hundred thousand-plus on Instagram yeah
yeah and for somebody who's you're
averse to it you don't like it you hate
it you only post once in a while you
don't really advertise what you're doing
at all but your own this huge following
of people who are super interested in
what you're doing well I think it's
important to do things you don't like
and I am I was very ashamed in my life
story for a long time IIIi didn't want
to go out and tell anybody about me so
that's why I had two people I you know I
create one david Goggins and one Goggins
right and i didn't want people to know
that i had all these issues but after a
while people start to give you these
different tag lines you know like you're
superhuman you're amazing they start all
right you don't know anything about me
man I'm this insecure kid I started
realizing there's a lot of people out
here who are going through a lot of
problems that I once tapped into you
know I had a whole bunch of she's
growing up and you know I felt compelled
to this you know what you got to start
sharing this stuff man cuz people see
where you're at today they see where
you're at today they see the man you are
they this this hard rock-hard human
being show these people where you come
from right
people as possible rule number 48 get
real with yourself
with my junior year in high school and I
felt back a lot I fell back in this
whole of life the second you think that
you've overcome it you climbed Everest
you're on that last hold and life was
saying not today you know push you down
and my junior in high school I missed a
whole bunch of school was lying my mom
had like a 1 point something GPA I was
just jacked up I mean it was I was in
when one of the worst parts of my life
and my mom was going through on us too
and she'd have time to sit back and baby
me and it was me against me
my pants were down to my knees I was
just I was not whatever was going on I
was in a bad shape so I went to the
bathroom and I had this weird haircut
because I wanted attention I was an
attention getter I went to an all-white
school pretty much some of the kids like
me allowed and didn't like me whatever
didn't matter I was looking for
something so I would dressed differently
crazy haircuts and I went to the mirror
and the reflection and it revealed a lot
of bad things a lot of things that I was
hiding behind the saggy pants and I'm
looking at myself in the mirror going
like God dog dude you got you are
something else man like you have created
a character I want to be the cool guy
table and whatever I could do to get
attention I did it wasn't me it wasn't
who I was inside but I was scared for
anybody know who I was inside so in that
kind of ability mirror I call it I got
real myself I said you have a third
grade reading level which is hard to
admit when you're a junior in high
school that you copied on every single
thing you did because a fear they're
gonna put me in a special school we all
know what special means I don't have a
title on myself the rest of my life and
being cool you don't have a title on
yourself
so I started cheating I was dumb and
people say oh he know your learning
disability I don't learn this to believe
I realized I was lazy so I called myself
out there I called myself out every
which way possible I call myself I was
as honest
I was honest look at yourself man look
at yourself and it was that day in a
couple of days after that I just got
real myself and every day I came home I
called the accountability mirror what am
I gonna do today to change what I see in
this mirror what am I gonna do today and
a lot of it was I stopped sit with the
cool guys I actually took my shirt in
with the school looking like a man this
I'm gonna look if you don't like it so
be it
I had to really wear this this this
layer of skin I had to develop a really
calloused skin on me there to take
whatever you're gonna call me you're
gonna call me whatever I'm gonna be I
want a geek but whoever I am you're
gonna see me you're gonna see me for who
I am because I need to change who I'm
not and that accountability member just
became wrong and I became fat over the
years guy fell back in the hole I called
myself fat because I was fat and people
don't want to do that they want to say
oh don't call yourself fat don't call
yourself dumb if you're not real and raw
with who the you are nothing's gonna
change in this nice new world that we
live in we want to hear you're just a
little big no man you might be fat and
it's okay to hear that from yourself
infirmary bells so that's where it
started at and it's raw it gets ugly
sometimes with me in that mirror but I'm
also proud of myself to be able to tell
myself that and then fix what's in that
mirror
rule number 49 take on challenges I'm
spraying for cockroaches when I got out
of the Air Force I sprayed for
cockroaches us about 297 to be exact and
I saw this Discovery Channel show on TV
and I was like and that Discovery
Channel show was this guy's going
through hell week and I saw these guys
freezing a lot of water and I was like
you know what it brought back memories
of me going through peer rescue training
so at 297 pounds I decided to try to be
a Navy SEAL and to make a long story
short how to lose a hundred and six
pounds in less than three
and that's where it became challenging
for me so I knew to lose 106 pounds in
less than three months we're looking at
3,500 calories
it's a pound so I was basically doing a
whole bunch of math in my head so I knew
if I were to stop and be stagnant there
was no calories being burned so I just
basically trained all day long so I saw
it went and before I knew it I've lost
the weight and rule number 50 the last
one before a very special bonus clip is
stay hard
well at that time of year again we start
to feel really happy why because we're
not going to work if you believe in
Santa Claus and you celebrate Christmas
you looking forward to Santa Claus
coming down the chimney giving you some
presents it's a real good time of year
so in a good time of year we start to
feel real good about ourselves so I
start to feel great so we start making
promises to ourselves about hey I'm
going to lose some weight I'm gonna do
better in school I'm gonna be better
here to be better there but guess what
happens
the real merry Christmas happens but all
of that noise is gone it's quiet and
it's you against you and now all those
endorphins are gone and I promise you
made by getting up early and getting
after to go lose weight study harder
guess what it's lot harder now that
repetition becomes a lot harder now
so labas can't do things on their own so
find somebody in your life so when you
throw that towel in they throw them back
at you and say you're not done yet
stay true to yourself stay hard I've got
a really special bonus gift from David
on how to overcome hardships that I
think you're gonna enjoy but before that
it's time for the three point landing
questions time to move from just
watching another video to taking action
your life for business and if you're
feeling bold leave your answers in the
comments below here we go question
number one where do you need to get in
charge of your brain number two what's
the finish line you need to stop looking
for and number three how will you stop
being your own worst enemy
you genuinely are legit badass at one
point in time you were a legit terrified
person yes so what was the process like
how did how did you step forth well it's
a it's a long process right I my dad be
Donnie was growing up we I was the first
black baby born in this hospital called
Millard Fillmore in Buffalo New York my
dad owned skating rinks he owned bars he
ran prostitutes from Canada to Buffalo
New York my dad was a big-time pimp
big-time anything bad about a person
big-time hustler he was American you
know that I'm with them Denzel
Washington he was that but not that bad
right yeah he wasn't that big but that's
what it reminds me of he was that kind
of guy and beat the [ __ ] out of me just
you know I loved my mom there was an
instant one time when my mom got knocked
out on top of stairs they drug her down
the stairs by her hair it has six years
old I'm gonna forget this in my mind I
was always afraid my whole life I was
afraid but I had this voice this this
conscience that would always be battling
me Stan hey you got to get up and do
something I didn't want to do like I was
this afraid but I would that that voice
would forced me to get up and my dad you
know I try to beat him up whatever at
6:00 and I get my ass kicked
so this went on for several years and I
have a big time learning disability can
my daddy that believe in us going to
school so my dad it was about the
business the skating rink in the bar so
this game you open about 7 o'clock at
night and this is time I was able to
walk so about 5 you know 4 or 5 6 years
old 8 9 and I go to this you know
skating rink it's 10 o'clock at night
and I worked the skating rink until
10:00 at night and then we would scrape
the gum off the floors and we cleaned
the whole skating rink up and then my
dad at the office and my brother and
myself was sleep in the office my mama
go upstairs and worked the bar until
three o'clock in the morning and then
they cleaned the bar up so after all
that [ __ ] was done with going to school
really happened so when I went to school
I was all kind of you know my learned
disability I had social anxiety I was
just a jacked up kid from living in this
tortured home
from the outside looking in we lived in
the all-white neighborhood and then we
would travel to the ghetto of Buffalo
New York with the skating rink was that
so we you know we worked around mostly
blacks and I lived around mostly whites
but no one knew what was going on their
house - on 201 Paradise Road yeah it's
crazy if you want more diamond Dawkins
check the work hard motivation video I
made the link is right there next to me
I think you'll enjoy it continue to
believe and I'll see you there I was
able to find strength in every molecule
of this earth
I'm able to be in a room with nothing
but no motivation or inspiration nothing
to find it